with theresa may on holiday it's the
turn of others to slog it through
westminster
parliament was the 99th mile mark for
yesterday's 100-mile ride london
politicians return here after the summer
they'll be on the brexit home leg
but having spent time with constituents
they may have found
the national mood is shifting
a new sky data poll has found 10 percent
of people think the government is doing
a good job negotiating brexit
78 say a bad job that's a 23 point
negative shift from when we asked the
question in march
65 percent now think we'll get a bad
deal
a 15 shift only 14 percent
think we'll get a good deal and will
brexit be good or bad for the country
overall
now only 40 percent say good while 51
say it will be bad what this poll tells
us is that as we're closing in on the
brexit finish line
more people are feeling worse about it
they're gloomier about what it means for
them
what it means to the economy and what it
means for the country
and now 50 of people want to say on
where we go from here
race official joanne can give you a
flavor of what people are thinking
what brexit was is not what it's become
i mean if anybody can actually tell us
what it is
we'd be in with half a chance wouldn't
we but you know that lot don't seem to
know
nobody seems to know so where are we who
knows
but here's where the study gets really
interesting we also asked
should there be another referendum with
three options the deal the government
gets
no deal or staying in the eu 50
said yes only 40 said no if that
happened on first
preferences 48 would vote to stay in the
eu
27 percent for a no deal brexit and just
13
backing the government deal so after
second preferences the poll suggests
59 would opt to stay in the eu
and 41 would go for a no deal brexit
we spoke to remain and leave voters in
theresa may's constituency of maidenhead
the country was split down the middle
and i think a lot of people are kind of
struggling with the idea that
um maybe
maybe it was the wrong decision it's
done now isn't that you know we're
near enough all the way through it's got
to kind of
all those i know it kind of sounds silly
but you've made your bed now you've got
to kind of lie in it isn't it as long as
it's gone on and we've actually heard
the politicians talking government they
don't know
they're arguing once themselves it's
actually embarrassing
the prime minister is having a hard
enough time selling her chequers plan to
european leaders but our poll suggests
it doesn't have support
at home more people than ever want a
second referendum
and our study finds that question would
ultimately lead
to the uk staying in the european union
jason farrell sky news